So Tig Notaro, you're coming onto the radio show today to talk about the last year of your life. Is this going to be an uplifting story?
Tig Notaro，你今天来到广播节目是为了谈谈你过去一年的生活。这会是一个令人振奋的故事吗？
[LAUGHS]. Well, it's not even a year. It's four months-- and no.
[笑]。其实甚至还没到一年，才四个月——不是。
Tig Notaro is a comedian. She was on our show this past spring telling the story-- maybe you heard this-- about Taylor Dayne. But in just four months she went through a series of terrible things, life changing things, including finally, two months after she was on our show this past May, she was diagnosed with cancer.
Tig Notaro 是一位喜剧演员。今年春天她曾来到我们的节目，讲了一个关于 Taylor Dayne 的故事——也许你听说过。但在短短四个月内，她经历了一系列可怕的、改变人生的事情，包括在今年五月做客我们节目两个月后，她被确诊患有癌症。
Her doctor called her with the test results on a Wednesday. Eight days later she was told that it was stage two and that it might be spreading throughout her body. And then the next night she did something that you don't see a lot of cancer patients do. She went on stage and did a stand-up set about it, about everything she was going through. She felt like she had to.
医生在一个周三给她打电话告知了检查结果。八天后，她被告知是二期癌症，而且可能已经扩散到全身。第二天晚上，她做了一件你很少看到癌症患者会做的事：她登台进行了一场脱口秀，讲述了她正在经历的一切。她觉得她必须这样做。
I really had the fear that if I walked away from this opportunity to perform that I would never be able to again.
我真的很担心，如果我放弃了这个表演机会，我就永远不会再有机会了。
Oh, wow. I didn't understand that.
噢，天哪。我之前没理解这一点。
Yeah. You know, my life could just start changing very quickly. I could immediately be on chemo. I could be ill. My past four months had shown me that who knows what's coming up.
是的。要知道，我的生活可能很快就会发生翻天覆地的变化。我可能马上就要进行化疗，可能就会病倒。过去四个月向我表明，谁也不知道接下来会发生什么。
The set she did at a club called Largo in Los Angeles became notorious in comedy circles immediately after it happened because another comedian, Louis CK, tweeted that it was one of the best sets he ever saw. It's not the kind of set that kills with joke after joke after joke. What makes it special is listening to it you can feel Tig figuring out how she's even going to talk about these things on stage as she's making her way through it.
她在洛杉矶一家名为 Largo 的俱乐部所做的这场表演，在事发后立刻在喜剧圈变得家喻户晓，因为另一位喜剧演员 Louis CK 在推特上说这是他看过的最好的表演之一。这不是那种靠一个接一个笑话就能炸场的表演。它的特别之处在于，听的时候你能感觉到 Tig 正在舞台上摸索，在经历这一切的同时，她该如何开口谈论这些事情。
It was scary. I picture myself walking and just kind of putting my tip-toe in front of me slowly, just, oh, I have no idea what this next line is going to be. I don't have any reference here.
这很可怕。我脑海里浮现出自己走着路，小心翼翼地把脚尖放在前面，心里想着：噢，我根本不知道下一句该说什么。我在这里没有任何参考。
You mean, what it's going to be, like how they're going to react.
你是说，你不知道那会是什么样的，以及他们会作何反应。
How they're going to react, and is this funny? I didn't know.
他们会作何反应，以及这到底好不好笑？我根本不知道。
Well, today on our radio show, "What Doesn't Kill You," we have stories of people who nearly die. Some of them nearly die more than once. And we see what it turns them into, who they are when they come back to the rest of us.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目“大难不死”中，我们要讲述那些差点死去的人的故事。有些人甚至不止一次差点死去。我们要看看这些经历将他们变成了什么样的人，当他们回到我们中间时，他们是谁。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是 Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, "Too Soon?" So we're going to start with that set that Tig Notaro performed the day after she heard that she had stage two cancer back in August. It's never been broadcast or released anywhere from now. This is going to be excerpt of the much longer half hour set.
第一幕，“是不是太早了？”我们要从 Tig Notaro 在八月份得知自己患有二期癌症的第二天所做的那个表演开始。这段录音从未在任何地方播出或发布过。这将是那场长达半小时的表演的片段。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
Good evening. Hello. I have cancer. How are you? Hi, how are you? Is everybody having a good time? I have cancer. How are you? Ah, it's a good time. Diagnosed with cancer. [SIGHS]. It feels good. Just diagnosed with cancer. Oh, God.
晚上好。大家好。我得了癌症。你们好吗？嗨，你们好吗？大家都过得开心吗？我得了癌症。你们好吗？啊，这真是个好时候。被诊断出患有癌症。[叹气]。感觉真好。刚刚被诊断出癌症。噢，天哪。
Oh, it's fine. Here's what happened. It's very personal. Found a lump. Guys, relax. Everything's fine. I have cancer.
噢，没关系。事情是这样的。这很私密。我发现了一个肿块。伙计们，放松点。一切都会好的。我得了癌症。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Found a lump, got a mammogram. I ended up getting biopsies, which is painful. It feels like being stabbed. I felt like I'd been rear-ended all day, and then just dropped off back at my house. I couldn't move or anything.
发现了一个肿块，去做了乳房 X 光检查。我最终做了活检，这很痛苦。感觉就像被刺伤了一样。我整天都觉得好像被人从后面撞了，然后被扔回了家里。我动弹不得，什么也做不了。
And it was so intrusive and horrible. And I was just like, God. After all of these like ice pick, stabbing feelings, I'd better have cancer.
这太令人痛苦和可怕了。我当时想，天哪。经历了这么多冰锥般的刺痛感，我最好真的是得了癌症。
Somebody over here just keeps going, oh. Oh, I think she might really have cancer. Who's taking this really bad? Oh. It's OK.
那边有个人一直在“噢，噢”地叫，我想她可能真的得了癌症。是谁觉得这事儿很糟糕吗？噢。没事的。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
It's OK. It's going to be OK. It might not be OK. But I'm just saying, it's OK. You're going to be OK. I don't know what's going on with me.
没事的。一切都会好起来的。也许不会好起来。但我只是想说，没事的。你会没事的。我也不知道自己身上发生了什么。
I literally got diagnosed just a few days ago. And this friend of mine, she was like, oh my gosh. I'm sure you've heard about these funny cancer greeting cards. And I go, whoa, whoa, whoa. You're sure I've heard about funny cancer greeting cards? I was like, I just got diagnosed.
我真的是几天前才被确诊的。我的一个朋友说，噢天哪，我相信你一定听说过那些有趣的癌症贺卡。我说，等等，等等。你确定我一定听说过有趣的癌症贺卡？我说，我才刚被确诊。
I didn't just go out and learn all about the subculture, and start buying knickknacks, and like, no. I don't know about the funny cancer greeting cards. I just don't know. I just got diagnosed.
我又没有去深入了解那种亚文化，开始买些小饰品之类的，不。我不知道什么有趣的癌症贺卡。我就是不知道。我才刚被确诊。
And so my friend texted me one of the cards. The outside of the card says-- oh, what is it? So you have cancer. Sad face. Then you open the card. And it says, thank goodness. I've been looking for a reason to shave my head.
然后我的朋友给我发了一张贺卡。贺卡外面写着——噢，写的是什么来着？哦，你得了癌症。悲伤的表情。然后你打开贺卡。上面写着：谢天谢地，我一直在找理由剃光头。
[HESITANT LAUGHTER]
[犹豫的笑声]
I can't believe that's what you guys haven't laughed at tonight. That was straight from the funny cancer greeting cards.
我真不敢相信你们今晚竟然没因为这个笑出来。那可是出自有趣的癌症贺卡。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
What's odd, though, is having this diagnosis, it's such a weird time because I have so many amazing things going on in my life. Like, all of the best and all of the worst is exactly at the same time. In fact, at the end of March I had this-- basically a bacteria was eating my digestive system. So I had this bacteria eating my digestive tract. So I lost 20 pounds. I've put five back on.
奇怪的是，得到这个诊断结果，这是一个很诡异的时期，因为我的生活中同时发生着很多很棒的事情。比如，所有最好的和所有最坏的事情都在同一时间发生。事实上，三月底我得了这个——基本上是一种细菌在吞噬我的消化系统。所以我当时消化道里有细菌在吞噬。所以我瘦了 20 磅。后来又长回了 5 磅。
And just please bear with me. It's so hard, because right now in my life, when I have a show I don't feel like, oh, I want to go talk about how funny it is that a bee was taking the 405 freeway. Like all the jokes that I've written, I just am like, I can't even bring myself to talk about it.
请多包涵。这真的很难，因为我现在的生活中，当我有一场演出时，我并不想说：“噢，我想谈谈一只蜜蜂走 405 号高速公路是多么好笑。”我写的所有笑话，我只是觉得，我甚至无法让自己谈论它们。
Because-- and just, everyone relax-- my mother just died. Should I leave? My mother just died-- tragically, too. She was 65, she tripped, hit her head, and died, a week after I got out of the hospital.
因为——大家放松——我母亲刚刚去世了。我该走吗？我母亲刚刚去世了——还是以一种悲剧性的方式。她 65 岁，绊倒了，撞到了头，在我出院一周后就去世了。
What happened was after we buried her in our hometown in Mississippi, we drove back to Texas. And I was checking the mail. And the hospital sent my mother a questionnaire to see how her stay at the hospital went.
事情是这样的，在我们把她安葬在我们密西西比的家乡后，我们开车回到了德克萨斯。我在查邮件。医院给我的母亲寄了一份调查问卷，看看她在医院住得怎么样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Hm-- not great. Did not go great. The questionnaire asked things such as, number one, during this hospital stay, did nurses explain things in a way you could understand? I mean, considering you had zero brain activity.
嗯——不怎么样。住得不太好。问卷上问了一些问题，比如：第一，在住院期间，护士是否以你能理解的方式解释了情况？我想，考虑到她当时大脑已经没有任何活动了。
Number two, was the area around your room quiet at night? Or could you hear the 12 hours of your daughter alone at your bedside sobbing and telling you things she wished she was brave enough to tell you when you were conscious? Number four, suggestions for improvements. Such as, should we stop sending questionnaires to dead people?
第二，你房间周围晚上安静吗？还是说你能听到你女儿在你床边独自哭泣了 12 个小时，告诉你她在你清醒时不够勇敢说出来的话？第四条，改进建议。比如，我们是不是应该停止给死人寄调查问卷了？
When I was-- I'm jumping around a lot-- I'm going back to the cancer. I'm bailing on the mother thing. After I got the biopsies, they did another mammogram. And I had to have my shirt off. And I was standing there at the machine. And the technician said, oh my gosh, you have such a flat stomach. What is your secret? And I was like, oh, I'm dying.
当我在——我思维跳跃得太厉害了——我回到癌症的话题上。我放弃谈论我母亲的事情了。活检后，他们又给我做了次乳房 X 光检查。我得把衬衫脱掉。我站在机器旁。技术员说，噢天哪，你的肚子真平。你的秘诀是什么？我当时说，噢，我快死了。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
The condition I had in the hospital is called C diff. And so I just refer to it as the C diff diet. You just sit there and watch the pounds melt away. Don't like exercising? Who does, girlfriend? This diet does all the work for you. Just clear all the bacteria from your intestines and let the C diff whittle way at your waistline.
我在医院得的那种病叫艰难梭菌感染。所以我称它为艰难梭菌饮食法。你只要坐在那儿看着体重一点点消失。不喜欢运动？谁喜欢呢，姐妹？这种饮食法帮你完成了所有工作。只要清除肠道里的细菌，让艰难梭菌帮你减掉腰围。
So basically, the events-- I got pneumonia. I was in the hospital for a week for C diff. Got out. A week later, my mother died. I know, it's hilarious. Then I went through a break up, right in the middle of it all. It's tough times. You can't stick around for that. Got to get out before the cancer comes. Went through a break up.
所以基本上，发生的事件是——我得了肺炎。我因为艰难梭菌在医院住了一周。出院了。一周后，我母亲去世了。我知道，这太搞笑了。然后我经历了一次分手，就在这一切发生的时候。那是艰难的时期。你没法忍受那些。在癌症来临之前得赶紧离开。经历了一次分手。
Seems legit.
听起来很合理。
Seems totally legitimate. Who here is just wishing I would tell bees going down the 405?
听起来完全合理。在座的谁还在希望我讲蜜蜂走 405 号公路的故事？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I just can't. I'm sorry. [SIGHS]. But you know what's nice about all of this is that you can always rest assured that God never gives you more than you can handle. Never. Never. When you've had it, God goes, all right, that's it. I just keep picturing God going, you know what? I think she can take a little more.
我真的讲不了。抱歉。[叹气]。但你知道关于这一切，有一点很好的是，你可以永远放心，上帝绝不会给你超出你承受范围的重担。绝不。永远不会。当你已经承受了极限，上帝会说，好吧，够了。我总是想象上帝说，你知道吗？我觉得她还能再承受一点。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then the angels are standing back going, God, what are you doing? You are out of your mind. And God was like, no, no, no. I really think she can handle this. But why, God? Like, why? Why? I don't know. I just, you know. Just trust me on this.
然后天使们在后面说，上帝，你在做什么？你疯了吗。上帝说，不，不，不。我真的觉得她能应付这个。但是为什么，上帝？比如，为什么？为什么？我不知道。我只是，你知道。在这件事上相信我就好。
I heard another little sad [INAUDIBLE]. May you just should have stayed home. You know, what if I just transitioned right now into silly jokes right now?
我听到另一个悲伤的……[听不清]。也许你本来就应该待在家里。你知道，如果我现在突然转而去讲些愚蠢的笑话会怎么样？
No! No!
不！不！
No. I want to hear more bad news. No!
不。我想听更多坏消息。不！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Where are you?
你在哪儿？
Right here.
就在这儿。
Now I feel bad that I don't have more tragedy to share.
现在我觉得很糟糕，因为我没有更多的悲剧可以分享了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm honestly tapped out. Like that's all that happened to me. That's it.
我真的精疲力竭了。这就是发生在我身上的一切。就是这样。
OK, it's me again jumping in here. So after about half an hour of this, trying all kinds of stuff. Some that gets huge laughs, some stuff she's just kind of trying out and seeing. For example, she talks about getting a double mastectomy. She talks about her friends not knowing how to talk to her normally now that she has this diagnosis. There's a whole bit about will I date with cancer? And as the set is winding down, the audience requests the bee joke that she's been mentioning.
好的，又是我。在进行了半小时的尝试，用了各种东西后。有些带来了巨大的笑声，有些是她正在尝试和观察效果的。例如，她谈到了做双侧乳房切除术。她谈到了朋友们在得知她确诊后不知道该如何正常与她交谈。有一大段关于“我得癌症了还能约会吗”的内容。随着表演接近尾声，观众要求她讲讲她提到的那个蜜蜂笑话。
Tell the bee joke.
讲那个蜜蜂笑话。
Tell the bee joke? OK.
讲蜜蜂笑话？好吧。
And hearing her do the bee joke is like hearing her perform a version of herself which she knows doesn't even exist anymore.
听她讲那个蜜蜂笑话，就像在听她表演一个她自己也知道早已不存在的自我版本。
I was driving here.
我当时正开车来这里。
[LAUGHTER AND CHEERS]
[笑声和欢呼]
And ugh, just a lot of traffic.
噢，交通太堵了。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
And my car hadn't moved in several minutes. I was just sitting there. And my window was down. And a bee flew past me. Do you have any idea how frustrating it is when a bee passes you in 5 o'clock traffic? And PS, what was the bee doing taking the 405 in the first place?
我的车好几分钟都没动一下。我只是坐在那里。我的车窗是开着的。一只蜜蜂从我身边飞过。你知道在下午 5 点的交通拥堵中有一只蜜蜂超过你是多么令人沮丧吗？而且顺便问一下，那只蜜蜂一开始为什么要走 405 号公路？
Anyway, thanks so much for coming.
总之，非常感谢大家的到来。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Tig Notaro. What you just heard was less than half of what she did that night. The full thing is available, can be downloaded at Louis CK's website, louisck.net.
Tig Notaro。你们刚才听到的是她那天晚上表演的一半不到。完整版可以在 Louis CK 的网站 louisck.net 下载。
Yay, cancer! That's the best response I've ever gotten.
耶，癌症！这是我收到的最好的回应。
Act Two, "Just Keep Breathing." So this 13-year-old get bit by a shark. And it's harrowing, but not as harrowing as what happens after the attack. Because sharks are dangerous, but so are grown-ups.
第二幕，“坚持呼吸”。有个 13 岁的孩子被鲨鱼咬了。这很令人揪心，但不如袭击发生后的事情揪心。因为鲨鱼很危险，但成年人也一样危险。
The 13-year-old is now a grown-up herself. And she agreed to tell her story here on the radio. But she asked that I not give out her name. She was raised in this small town in New Zealand where everyone knew the shark story. And the last few years, she's been enjoying a life in America where that is not the very first thing that every single person she meets knows about her. And she wanted to try to keep that going by not outing herself on the radio.
那个 13 岁的孩子现在已经是个成年人了。她同意在电台讲述她的故事，但她要求我不要透露她的名字。她在新西兰的一个小镇长大，每个人都知道那个鲨鱼的故事。过去几年里，她在享受在美国的生活，在那里，这不是每个见到她的人首先知道的事情。她想通过不在电台上自曝身份来保持这种状态。
The attack happened when her family was out on a camping trip at the beach. She went for a swim with her friend.
袭击发生时，她的家人正在海滩露营。她和朋友去游泳。
It was beautiful. It was about dusk. We were walking out. The tide was really, really far out. And I wasn't even completely wet, slightly more than waist deep. And essentially, I walked straight into it. And they're incredibly powerful. It was like being hit by a freight train.
那时很美。大约是黄昏。我们正往外走。潮水退得很远很远。我甚至还没完全湿透，水深刚没过腰部。基本上，我是直接撞上了它。它们的力量太强大了。就像被一辆货运列车撞了一样。
It goes in. It got its teeth into me. And then I couldn't get out.
它咬住了我。然后我无法脱身。
She says the feeling of this was like the shark was trying to get inside her. It grabbed her on her right side, a few inches above the hip. The shark, as best as she could tell anyway, was about five feet long. She was just over five feet tall.
她说那种感觉就像鲨鱼试图钻进她身体里。它咬住了她的右侧，在髋部上方几英寸处。据她所知，那只鲨鱼大约五英尺长。她当时身高刚过五英尺。
The best analogy I can think of is that it's like a dog. It got its teeth in. And then it's shaking. It's like using that.
我能想到的最好的类比是，它就像一只狗。它咬住了。然后它在摇晃。就像在利用那个。
Oh, it's shaking you, like a dog shakes its head back and forth.
噢，它在摇晃你，就像狗摇头晃脑一样。
But it's trying to shake me to get me under the water. And so I'm trying to stand on my feet, like really trying to stand on my feet. And I want whatever it is inside of me out. So I want to win. I want to stand up.
但它是在试图把我拖到水下摇晃。所以我试图站稳脚跟，真的在努力站稳。我想把身体里的那个东西弄出去。所以我想赢。我想站起来。
Ultimately, it dragged me under three times. The first two times I got back up. But the third time I started taking in a lot of water. So I thought I was going to drown. And when it started to drown me, that's when I really hit it, scratched it, everything. It was just full-on-- your animal instincts come out. It's like hand-to-hand combat, kind of.
最终，它把我拖到了水下三次。前两次我爬了上来。但第三次我开始大量呛水。所以我以为我要淹死了。当它开始让我溺水时，我才真正开始击打它，抓它，一切都用了出来。那简直是——你的动物本能被激发了。就像近身肉搏一样。
But whatever happened, whatever I did, gave it enough of a fright that it stopped trying to drown me, and disengaged from my stomach.
但不管发生了什么，不管我做了什么，让它感到足够惊恐，它停止了试图淹死我，并松开了我的腹部。
She hobbled towards shore, sent her friend for help. A small chunk of skin was torn off. She had two big puncture wounds. Her swimsuit was half tattered.
她一瘸一拐地走向岸边，让朋友去求救。一块皮肤被撕掉了。她有两个大穿刺伤。她的泳衣半挂在身上。
And I know I'm losing blood. And I'm worried that that's going to attract either that shark back, or some other sharks. And then I get to a certain point where I'm in quite shallow water. And I just can't walk anymore.
我知道我正在失血。我很担心那会把那只鲨鱼或其他鲨鱼引回来。然后我到了一个水很浅的地方。我实在走不动了。
So I lie down. And it's shallow enough that I can lie down. And I can feel blood everywhere. And these fishermen come along. Are you all right? And I'm patently not all right.
所以我躺了下来。水够浅，我可以躺下。我能感觉到到处都是血。这些渔夫过来了。你还好吗？但我显然不太好。
But the other issue is that I'm exposed, like I'm quite naked. And I'm 13. So I'm like, oh, I'm fine. I'm fine. And they're like, hm, you don't look fine. I'm like, I'm OK. I'm OK, you carry on.
但另一个问题是，我暴露了，我几乎是赤身裸体。我才 13 岁。所以我就说，噢，我很好。我很好。他们说，嗯，你看上去不太好。我说，我没事。我没事，你们继续吧。
Like, well, we'd like to take you out of the water. I'm like, hm. And then at a certain point, they just stop trying to negotiate and just pick me up. And I'm dying of shame. I am just dying of shame.
他们说，我们想把你带出水面。我说，嗯。然后在某个时刻，他们停止了商量，直接把我抱了起来。我当时羞愧得要死。我真的羞愧得要死。
On the beach, a small crowd starts to form. Of course, to her horror. Her parents show up and drive her to the nearest town, which she remembers as 30 minutes away. Though her mom remembers it as 15 to 20.
在海滩上，人群开始聚集。当然，这让她感到恐怖。她的父母赶来，开车带她去最近的城镇，她记得那需要 30 分钟。但她母亲记得是 15 到 20 分钟。
It's such a tiny town in a remote part of New Zealand that there's no hospital there. It's Friday night. So they have to call the local doctor to come in to open up this little medical office.
那是新西兰偏远地区的一个小镇，小到那里没有医院。那是周五晚上。所以他们不得不打电话给当地医生，让他过来打开这个小诊所。
The doctor and my dad-- everyone's sort of quite jovial, they're kind of relieved. And I remember them talking-- my dad and the doctor-- talking about the cricket.
医生和我爸爸——大家都挺开朗的，他们松了一口气。我记得他们当时在聊——我爸爸和医生——在聊板球。
Did they not seem like they were in a big hurry? The way you describe it--
他们看起来一点都不着急吗？按照你的描述——
No. So I just remember him cleaning up the wound, and immediately pulling all this skin I'd lost together, and then stitching that. He gave me a tetanus shot. He said to my parents, I might act a little bit strange that night, a little bit odd, because I might be in shock. They should ignore me. I'd be fine.
没有。我只记得他清理伤口，立刻把我失去的皮肤缝合在一起。他给我打了一针破伤风疫苗。他对我父母说，我晚上可能会表现得有点奇怪，有点不寻常，因为我可能处于休克状态。他们应该忽略我。我会没事的。
Now these instructions from the doctor play a big part in what is about to follow. They've become part of family lore. So I just want to hold on this point for one more moment. The doctor said-- or anyway, they remember him saying--
现在，医生的这些指示在接下来的事情中起到了很大作用。它们已经成了家族传说。所以我想在这个点上再多停留一会儿。医生说——或者无论如何，他们记得他说——
I can't remember the exact words. But it was essentially, she'll be fine. You know, she'll be dramatic about this. Kids can get a little extreme about this stuff. But everything's OK. Ignore it.
我不记得具体话语了。但本质上是说，她会没事的。你知道，她会对这件事反应过激。孩子们对这些事可能会有点极端。但一切都会好起来的。不用管她。
Then we leave. And we go back. So we're in a caravan camping.
然后我们就离开了。我们回去了。我们在露营车里露营。
The caravan's like an RV?
露营车就像房车一样？
Yeah.
是的。
Remember, they're on vacation. It's her parents and her three siblings, all younger. She's in pain. But the doctor said she'd be in pain.
记住，他们是在度假。是她的父母和三个年幼的弟弟妹妹。她很痛苦。但医生说她会很痛苦。
And normally I have to sleep on a top bunk in an awning outside. But I was allowed to stay in the caravan that night. And it's kind of hard to describe how painful it was. But essentially, very quickly I start vomiting up blood and stomach lining. Or I assume it's stomach lining. Like, it's sort of a jelly-like substance. I don't know what it is at the time.
通常我得睡在外面遮阳篷的上铺。但那天晚上我被允许待在露营车里。很难形容有多痛苦。但基本上，我很快就开始呕吐血液和胃粘膜。或者我假设那是胃粘膜。就像是一种果冻状的物质。我当时不知道那是什么。
And so I just go and get a plastic cup out of the cupboard and start to collect it. Because I didn't want to get the caravan dirty. And in the midst of this, everyone else goes to bed. And it just keeps getting worse and worse. It feels like I'm on fire. Like every atom in my body is in an inferno.
所以我从橱柜里拿了一个塑料杯开始接这些东西。因为我不想把露营车弄脏。在这期间，其他人都去睡觉了。情况变得越来越糟。感觉就像我在燃烧。就像我身体里的每一个原子都在地狱般的火焰中。
And so I go and tell my parents. I wake them up. And I say, I'm on fire. I'm burning up. And they were-- go back to sleep. Come on, you'll be fine.
所以我去告诉父母。我把他们叫醒。我说，我在燃烧。我在发高烧。他们说——回去睡觉。得了吧，你会没事的。
This, after all, was what the doctor told them was going to happen. She'd be uncomfortable, that was normal, nothing to worry about. This continues all night. She throws up blood into a cup, feels feverish.
毕竟，这就是医生告诉他们会发生的事情。她会不舒服，这很正常，不用担心。这种情况持续了一整夜。她把血吐进杯子里，感到发烧。
What's actually happening, everybody's going to learn later, is that the shark has bitten through her bowel in several places. So the contents of her bowels are slowly leaking into her gut, basically poisoning her. She's developing sepsis and peritonitis. She is bleeding internally. One side effect of all this is that her lungs start filling with liquids, making it increasingly difficult for her to breathe.
每个人后来才知道，实际上发生的是，鲨鱼咬穿了她的肠道好几处。所以肠道的内容物正在慢慢渗漏进她的腹腔，基本上是在毒害她。她正在产生败血症和腹膜炎。她在内出血。这一切的一个副作用是她的肺部开始积液，使她呼吸变得越来越困难。
And at that point, my mother-- this is during the night-- and I was saying, I can't breathe. I can't breath. And she said, mind over matter-- stop that hyperventilating. Which has become a family joke. Where now any time someone says, I've got a cold, we're like, mind over matter-- stop that hyperventilating.
就在那时，我母亲——这是在夜里——我说，我不能呼吸了。我不能呼吸了。她说，心境决定一切——别再过度通气了。这成了一个家庭笑话。现在只要有人说“我感冒了”，我们就说“心境决定一切——别再过度通气了”。
And it gets a lot worse. I am incredibly weak. I can't breathe. And then eventually I could just feel I was losing my ability to keep going. And again, during the night I try again. And I wake them up. And I say, I'm dying. And again, they're just like, come on.
情况变得糟糕多了。我极其虚弱。我不能呼吸。最终我能感觉到我正在失去继续支撑下去的能力。同样，在夜里我再次尝试。我叫醒他们。我说，我要死了。他们还是说，得了吧。
For me, I was like, come on. I've made this pretty clear. I have done everything I can to communicate this to you.
对我来说，我当时想，得了吧。我已经表达得很清楚了。我已经竭尽全力与你们沟通了。
I love how this is like exactly what it's like to be 13, is that you have urgent things that you're telling people around you, and adults just kind of shrug it off. But in this case, it's completely real. And you need them to actually pay attention to this one.
我喜欢这种感觉，这就像 13 岁时的真实写照：你有极其紧急的事情要告诉周围的人，而大人们只是耸耸肩不当回事。但在这种情况下，这是完全真实的。你需要他们真正关注这件事。
Right. And there isn't an alternative. Like, I live on or die based on convincing them.
对。而且没有别的选择。我的生死取决于能否说服他们。
And it's not working.
但他们没当回事。
There's no plan B. There's no taking my dad's car keys and driving. I can't drive. It's before I had a phone. I can't ring anyone.
没有 B 计划。没法拿走我爸的车钥匙开车。我不会开车。那时候我还没有电话。我没法给任何人打电话。
Now I talked to her parents to answer the question that might be forming in your head right this second. They do not seem like terrible people, or the worst parents I have ever met. They both understand how they screwed up that night.
现在我跟她的父母谈过，以回答你们心中此刻可能正在形成的疑问。他们看起来并不像是可怕的人，也不是我见过的最糟糕的父母。他们俩都明白那天晚上他们有多失职。
Her mom told me, yes, she knows this all looks very bad in retrospect. And they should have listened to their kid. Yes, her dad said. She woke them up. She said she was dying. They didn't do anything. It all looked very different later.
她母亲告诉我，是的，她知道回过头来看这一切看起来很糟糕。他们本应该听孩子的。是的，她父亲说。她叫醒了他们。她说她要死了。他们什么都没做。事后看来完全是另一回事。
In their defense, they both pointed out that, at the time, the liquid that she was throwing up looked more brown to them than blood-red. They both assumed that it was Coca-Cola, which she had been drinking. And not to excuse their actions, but simply as context for the "stop hyperventilating" remark, her mom pointed out that, at that age, her daughter did hyperventilate when she was nervous about all kinds of things, like a music performance at school.
为他们辩护的是，他们俩都指出，当时她吐出来的液体在他们看来更接近棕色而不是鲜红色。他们俩都以为那是她一直在喝的可乐。而且不是为了给“别再过度通气”那句话找借口，只是作为语境，她母亲指出，在她那个年纪，女儿在对各种事情感到紧张时确实会过度通气，比如学校的音乐演出。
When the sun came up the next morning, their daughter was pale, having a terrible time getting in enough air to breathe. And then her eyes rolled back in her head. Her mom saw the whites of her eyes. And she said she felt like she was falling through the surface of the Earth. She had somebody call the doctor's office. They were coming in. Her daughter picks up the story.
第二天早上太阳升起时，他们的女儿面色苍白，呼吸困难。然后她的眼睛翻了上去。她母亲看到了她眼中的眼白。她说她感觉自己像是从地球表面坠落了下去。她让人给医生打了电话。他们正在赶来。她女儿接过了故事。
The problem is my dad's taken the car to visit various fishermen with the scraps of my swimming suit. Because he's trying to find out what happened. Because it's still out there.
问题是我爸爸把车开走去找各种渔夫，带着我泳衣的碎片。因为他想找出发生了什么。因为它还在那儿。
Actually, whether it was a shark or some other creature is still in some dispute. Her dad says that the town listed it officially as a stingray attack, so it wouldn't hurt tourism. A New Zealand shark expert told us that if it were not a shark it could either be a stingray or a fur seal. But it would be impossible to tell that without a photograph of the wound, which we were unable to locate in time for our broadcast. Anyway, back to our story.
实际上，到底是鲨鱼还是其他生物仍有争议。她父亲说镇上将其正式列为黄貂鱼袭击，以免影响旅游业。一位新西兰鲨鱼专家告诉我们，如果不是鲨鱼，那可能是黄貂鱼或毛皮海豹。但如果不拍伤口照片就无法判断，我们没能及时找到照片用于广播。总之，回到我们的故事。
So he comes back. Then you get in the car?
所以他回来了。然后你上车了？
Get in the car, back to the backseat. And that was a really long journey.
上车，回到了后座。那真是一段漫长的旅程。
A long journey, because by this point, there is so much fluid in her lungs that it's taking all of her concentration to keep enough air going in and out. It's exhausting.
漫长的旅程，因为此时此刻，她的肺部已经充满了液体，以至于她所有的注意力都必须用来保持空气正常进出。这让人精疲力竭。
And I knew it was a long way away. And I knew-- at that point, I started to doubt whether I would be able to keep doing what I'd been doing for a long time.
我知道路还很长。我知道——在那一点上，我开始怀疑自己是否还能继续坚持做我一直在做的事情。
And so what do you remember of that trip?
那你还记得那段旅程吗？
We're making reasonable progress. But at a certain point, we hit a bridge. And there's a farmer moving his sheep across the bridge. So we're blocked. And I hadn't factored that into my-- this is how long I can keep myself going. And at that point, I really felt I lost it.
我们进展还算顺利。但在某个时刻，我们碰到了一座桥。有个农民正在赶羊过桥。所以我们被挡住了。我没把这个计入我的——这是我能坚持多久的时间预期。在那一点上，我真的觉得自己撑不住了。
She started losing consciousness. But she describes it as lifting off in an airplane. It felt good. Though she fought it.
她开始失去知觉。但她描述它像是坐飞机起飞。感觉很好。尽管她一直在抗拒。
Any time I felt myself losing consciousness, I wanted to come back. I remember, like, willing myself. And that was tough. Because when you're drifting off into unconsciousness there's no pain. And I've been in pain for so long now, in such extreme pain. So it, each time, took a lot of effort to be like, actually, I'm coming back.
每当我感到失去知觉时，我都想回来。我记得像是强迫自己一样。那很难。因为当你漂入昏迷时，没有痛苦。而我经历了那么长时间的痛苦，极致的痛苦。所以每一次，都要花费很大的努力才能说，实际上，我要回来。
Her mom was in the back seat with her. And her mom told me that when they stopped on the bridge, there was a noticeable change. Her daughter's body seemed to get very light. She told her husband to hurry.
她母亲当时在后座陪着她。她母亲告诉我，当他们在桥上停下时，发生了明显的变化。女儿的身体似乎变得很轻。她告诉丈夫要快点。
Finally, they arrived at the medical office. She can't speak, can't move. But she's still conscious. There are now either three or four doctors, depending on whose memory you rely on.
最终，他们到达了医疗诊所。她无法说话，无法动弹。但她还有知觉。现在有三四名医生，取决于你相信谁的记忆。
She's put on a table. And she hears the doctor say something to her parents that she can't quite make out, but that seems to be either she's dying, or possibly, she's dead.
她被放在桌子上。她听到医生对她父母说了一些她听不清的话，但听起来要么是她快死了，要么可能是，她已经死了。
I remember them reacting very badly. So I remember my dad saying, she was my favorite daughter. And at the time, I was like, yes. Because I have two sisters.
我记得他们反应非常糟糕。我记得我爸爸说，她是我最喜欢的女儿。当时我想，是的。因为我有两个姐妹。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And at the other end of the scale, I remember my mom saying, just like the cat. Because our cat, Winkles, had recently made an untimely end. And so that was a bad situation.
而在天平的另一端，我记得我母亲说，就像那只猫一样。因为我们的猫 Winkles 最近不幸过世了。所以那是一个糟糕的情况。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Just like the cat?
就像那只猫一样？
It's brutal.
这太残酷了。
The parents do confirm these quotes. Her dad remembers saying, that was my favorite daughter. He said it was obvious that she might die. He was haranguing the doctor to do something now. Her mom does not remember, but says that it is very possible she declared, just like the cat. Because Winkles had died of internal injuries after its stomach was perforated, very similar to their daughter.
父母确认了这些话。她父亲记得曾说过，那是他最喜欢的女儿。很明显她可能要死了。他在斥责医生立即做点什么。她母亲不记得了，但说很有可能她说了“就像那只猫一样”。因为 Winkles 在胃穿孔后因内伤死亡，和他们的女儿非常相似。
And I do remember my dad getting angry. And then there's an exchange between him and the doctor. And then the next thing I know is the doctor comes back, gets out a blade. I didn't see it. I felt it. And just slices into my arm. It wasn't like they gave me anesthetic. They just took out a blade and hacked into my arm.
我确实记得我爸爸变得很生气。然后他和医生之间发生了争执。接下来我知道的是，医生回来，拿出了一把刀片。我没看见它。我感觉到了。直接割进了我的手臂。他们没给我打麻醉。他们只是拿出刀片，砍进了我的手臂。
And what do you think happened?
你当时认为发生了什么？
I don't know. I think they're performing an autopsy on me. Because no one's talking to me. I am so irrelevant in this whole situation because I can't communicate. And they're in the middle of an autopsy. And I can't say anything to anyone.
我不知道。我想他们是在对我进行尸检。因为没人跟我说话。在这整个情况中，我完全不重要，因为我没法沟通。他们正在进行尸检。我却什么都说不了。
Oh my God.
噢，天哪。
And I can't communicate. I don't have control over my body.
我没法沟通。我没法控制自己的身体。
Doctors slice into her arms and ankles. She still had inch-long scars that she showed me. She says it's hard to believe that when they sliced into your ankles with no anesthesia, it hurt worse than being attacked in the water.
医生割开了她的手臂和脚踝。她仍然留有英寸长的疤痕，她给我看了。她说很难相信，当他们不打麻醉割开你的脚踝时，竟然比在水里被袭击更痛。
I'm worried that the next thing he's going to do is cut my throat. Because I don't understand. I don't understand why they're cutting my ankles. There was no shark attack on my ankles. My feet are fine.
我担心接下来他要做的是割断我的喉咙。因为我不明白。我不明白他们为什么要割我的脚踝。我的脚踝又没被鲨鱼咬。我的脚很好。
The way she remembers it, when they cut into her ankles, she jolted. And they realized at that point that she was alive. And they called the helicopter to fly her to a proper hospital.
在她记忆中，当他们割开她的脚踝时，她猛地跳了一下。他们在那一刻意识到她还活着。他们叫了直升机把她飞往一家正规医院。
At least, that's how she saw it at the time. The reality was different. I reached one of the doctors who worked on her that day, Dr. Vic Eastman. He was trained in emergency room medicine. And he says that they definitely were not performing an autopsy. He said that she was in such a state of shock, she lost so much blood. They believed that if they didn't get IVs into her immediately, she would die.
至少，那是她当时的看法。事实并非如此。我联系了那天救治她的医生之一 Vic Eastman 博士。他是急诊医学出身的。他说他们绝对没有进行尸检。他说她当时处于深度休克状态，失血过多。他们认为如果不立即给她输液，她就会死亡。
Cutting into the arms and ankles is what doctors do to find a vein in that situation when there is so little blood pressure. This is a standard ER procedure. And they didn't feel like they had the time to stop and anesthetized her.
割开手臂和脚踝是医生在这种血压极低的情况下寻找静脉的方法。这是急诊的标准程序。他们觉得没有时间停下来给她打麻醉。
They did call in helicopters. She was flown to a hospital in the city of Nelson, where she was operated on. For a while, it didn't seem like she was going to survive. She went into a coma, and woke up days later.
他们确实叫了直升机。她被飞往尼尔森市的一家医院，并在那里接受了手术。有一段时间，看起来她撑不过去了。她陷入了昏迷，几天后醒来。
And I was in an intensive care unit. And the male nurse was saying, Mom, get in her eye sight. He's coming around. She's coming around. And my mom looked over, and she said, aren't you lucky the doctors saved you?
我在重症监护室。那个男护士在说，妈妈，进到她的视线里。她要醒了。她要醒了。我母亲看过来，说，医生救了你，你真幸运。
And I couldn't talk, because I was on life support ventilator for my lungs so that I could breathe. And I indicated for paper and pencil. And I wrote, I saved myself. Underline, underline, underline.
我没法说话，因为我戴着人工呼吸机来辅助呼吸。我示意要纸和笔。我写道：是我自救的。下划线，下划线，下划线。
When somebody asks her to tell this story, what happened the day after she was bit by the shark-- or whatever it was-- it's possible for her to get mad all over again. But it usually doesn't come up. She doesn't think about it.
当有人要求她讲这个故事——被鲨鱼——或者不管是什么东西——咬伤后的第二天发生了什么时，她可能会再次愤怒。但通常不会。她不常去想它。
And she's fine with her parents. Her relationship with them is pretty much like anybody's. And she understands their actions that day. Everybody moved on.
她和父母关系很好。她和他们的关系和其他人差不多。她理解他们那天的行为。大家都向前看了。
I mean, they subsequently bought a house just along from where the whole thing happened. And I was very anti that plan.
他们后来就在事情发生的附近买了一套房子。我当时非常反对那个计划。
Wait, they bought a house right near where it happened?
等等，他们就在事发地点附近买了一套房子？
Right.
对。
Like a vacation house?
就像度假屋那样？
Yeah, in this very remote community. And I was like, I'm going to boycott that. But you can't. We went back the next year to the same camping spot.
是的，在这个非常偏远的社区。我说，我要抵制这个计划。但你没法抵制。第二年我们又回到了同一个露营点。
It was a family with four kids. Nobody was inclined to dwell on the past, including her. Within a year, her dad had started buying joke presents about it-- a necklace with a shark, and a swimmer coming out of its mouth. Or a t-shirt with a cartoon shark bite, fake blood splatters, and a hole-- a real hole in the shirt-- coincidentally, right where her actual bite was.
这是一个有四个孩子的家庭。没人愿意沉溺于过去，包括她。一年之内，她父亲就开始给她买关于这件事的玩笑礼物——一个带着鲨鱼的项链，还有一个游泳者从鲨鱼嘴里出来。或者一件印着卡通鲨鱼咬痕的 T 恤，上面有假的血迹，还有一个洞——衬衫上真的有一个洞——巧合的是，正好在她实际被咬的位置。
The fact that she nearly died, that was the past. She wore the shirt and the necklace. And then quietly, after a while, she had enough of it.
她差点死去的事实，那是过去。她穿着那件 T 恤，戴着那条项链。后来静静地，过了一段时间，她受够了。
Coming up, when you're little, you learn that you are supposed to be careful with sharp, dangerous objects. You learn that you are not supposed to put dangerous things into your mouth. In a minute, somebody who ignores both those rules-- really, really ignores them. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，当你还是个孩子时，你学会了要小心锋利的危险物品。你学会了不应该把危险的东西放进嘴里。一会儿，有个完全无视这两个规则的人——真的，非常彻底地无视了它们。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "What Doesn't Kill You." We have stories of people surviving all kinds of things, and where they end up on the other side of that. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, "A Real Nail Biter."
这是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。今天的节目，“大难不死”。我们要讲述人们在各种事情中幸存下来，以及在另一端他们的归宿。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“令人焦虑的咬指甲时刻”。
This story is amazing. Because the woman that it's about, I think more than anybody else on today's show, probably should not be around to tell the story. Reporter Jessica Benko tells what happened.
这个故事太不可思议了。因为这个故事的主人公，我觉得比今天节目里的任何人都更不应该活着来讲这个故事。记者 Jessica Benko 讲述了发生的事情。
The woman's name is Cathy. And the thing that almost killed her over and over was a thought. It first appeared one day when she was 12 or 13 years old. She was in a psychiatric institution at the time.
这个女人的名字叫 Cathy。那个一遍又一遍差点杀了她的东西是一个念头。它第一次出现是在她 12 或 13 岁的时候。当时她在一个精神病院。
Cathy asked that I not use her full name on the radio. And she didn't want to discuss certain events of her childhood. She hopes it's enough to describe it as troubled. But she threw violent tantrums as a kid, assaulted her teachers, and even began cutting herself. So Cathy's doctors had convinced her parents an institution might help her. But it was there that the thought first came to her.
Cathy 要求我不要在电台上使用她的全名。她不想讨论童年的某些事件。她希望用“动荡”来形容就足够了。但她小时候会发暴烈的脾气，攻击老师，甚至开始自残。所以 Cathy 的医生说服了她的父母，机构可能会帮助她。但就是在那里，那个念头第一次闪过了她的脑海。
I was in the quiet room. Quiet rooms are a room that's smaller than the size of a bathroom-- a good-sized bathroom. And it's all concrete. And they have this mattress on the floor that has no springs in it. It's a safety mattress.
我在静谧室。静谧室是一个比浴室——一个好尺寸的浴室——还小的房间。全都是混凝土做的。地板上有一个没有弹簧的床垫。那是安全床垫。
And I found a nail. At first, I wanted to use it on my arm to cut myself. So I hid it, because I knew if I got caught with it they would take it. And then I got the thought to swallow it.
我发现了一枚钉子。起初，我想把它用在胳膊上切开自己。所以我把它藏了起来，因为我知道如果被发现，他们会把它拿走。然后我产生了一个吞下它的念头。
I wanted to feel it go down my throat and go into my stomach.
我想感受它滑过喉咙进入胃里的感觉。
Out of anger and frustration, or something else?
是因为愤怒和挫败感，还是其他原因？
Nope.
不。
Curiosity?
好奇心？
Out of a compulsion, like the thought. The thought wouldn't leave me alone. And I just did it.
出于一种强迫症，就像那个念头。那个念头不放过我。我只是照做了。
Cathy says it felt good to swallow the nail. And once it was in her stomach, she felt intense relief. The thought was no longer nagging her. Doctors put her in the hospital and waited for the nail to pass. But once it was gone, the thought returned with increasing frequency, again and again.
Cathy 说吞下钉子感觉很好。一旦它进了胃里，她感到极大的解脱。那个念头不再折磨她了。医生把她送进医院，等待钉子排出。但一旦它排出，那个念头又更频繁地出现，一次又一次。
It was horrible. I was tortured. I literally was tortured in my mind. I've swallowed pencils, hundreds of pencils, multiple toothbrushes, nails, a plastic fork, knives, two antennas-- radio antennas. I swallowed a chess piece, a book bracket. I don't know what it's called, the thing that goes on a shelf, it holds the shelf. Oh, yeah, battery and glass.
这太可怕了。我受到了折磨。我的思想确实受到了折磨。我吞过铅笔，几百支铅笔，多支牙刷，钉子，塑料叉子，刀子，两根天线——无线电天线。我吞过一颗国际象棋棋子，一个书架支架。我不知道它叫什么，就是那种装在架子上支撑隔板的东西。噢，还有电池和玻璃。
All of this sounds intolerably painful. But for Cathy, it was even more agonizing when she wasn't able to swallow something, when she wasn't able to appease the thought. Cathy told my producer Brian Reed and me about one day when she snatched a straw from the common area of the psych ward. She hid it in her bra, hoping to swallow it the next chance she got. But the staff strip-searched her before she could do it.
这一切听起来都痛苦不堪。但对 Cathy 来说，当她无法吞下东西，无法安抚那个念头时，这种折磨更甚。Cathy 和我的制片人 Brian Reed 以及我谈起过有一天，她从精神病房的公共区域抢走了一根吸管。她把它藏在胸罩里，希望能有机会吞下它。但工作人员在她吞下之前对她进行了搜身。
And they found it on me. And I flipped. I just lost control. I started banging my head on the mirror in the bathroom where they strip-searched me, saying, please don't take it. You're going to kill me. You don't understand how much this-- I got to have it. And they ended up restraining me, and putting me in restraints, and giving me injections until I fell asleep.
他们在我身上发现了它。我崩溃了。我完全失去了控制。我开始把头撞向搜身浴室里的镜子，一边喊着：请不要拿走它。你会杀了我的。你不明白这对我来说——我必须有它。他们最终控制住了我，把我绑了起来，并给我注射药物直到我睡着。
Why were you so upset?
你为什么那么难过？
Because I thought I was going to die. I thought my mother was going to die.
因为我以为我会死。我以为我母亲会死。
Cathy isn't using metaphor here. She genuinely believed this irrational thought that if she didn't swallow the object she had fixated on, she or her mother would die. She says having the object inside her felt like a protection.
Cathy 这里没有使用比喻。她真诚地相信那个不理性的念头：如果她不吞下她固定关注的那个物体，她或她母亲就会死。她说把东西放在体内感觉像是一种保护。
Cathy was given a lot of diagnoses over the years. But doctors believe her swallowing was a symptom of obsessive-compulsive disorder. This is the same disorder that causes people who are afraid of germs to wash their hands incessantly, or others who are worried about a fire to check the stove dozens of times before they can leave the house. Cathy's fear about her or her mother's safety was a more extreme and illogical version of this.
多年来，Cathy 得到了很多诊断。但医生认为她的吞咽行为是强迫症（OCD）的症状。这就是导致那些害怕细菌的人不停洗手，或者担心火灾的人在离家前检查炉子几十次的人的那种疾病。Cathy 对她自己或母亲安全的恐惧是这种疾病更极端、更不合逻辑的版本。
Doctors didn't have a good cure. No matter what they tried-- therapy, drugs, repeated electroshock treatments-- they could not stop the thought from torturing Cathy. All they could do was try to stop Cathy from hurting herself. She couldn't be trusted on her own, so she was permanently institutionalized and put in four-point restraints.
医生没有什么好的治愈方法。无论他们尝试什么——治疗、药物、反复的电休克疗法——都无法停止那个念头折磨 Cathy。他们唯一能做的是阻止 Cathy 伤害自己。她不能被独自信任，所以她被长期关在精神病院，并处于四点式束缚中。
Four-point restraints is when they tie leather down to the bed, and they have handcuffs on the feet, and on the legs, on the arms.
四点式束缚是指他们用皮带把人绑在床上，脚踝和手腕上都有手铐。
On top of this, Cathy was constantly supervised by one, and sometimes even two staff members. But that didn't stop her from swallowing things. By law, every eight hours staff had to let her walk around for 15 minutes. Those 15 minutes were Cathy's chance to act.
最重要的是，Cathy 受到一名、有时甚至两名工作人员的持续监护。但这并不能阻止她吞东西。根据法律，每八小时工作人员必须让她走动 15 分钟。那 15 分钟是 Cathy 行动的机会。
And this is where I would scout things. So I would see what I wanted. And then I wouldn't sleep that night. I'd plan it to a T. It's like playing Stratego, but playing for, like, 24 hours without winning or without losing, but in the end knowing you're going to win.
这就是我搜寻东西的地方。我会看到我想要的。然后我那晚就睡不着了。我会精确地规划它。就像下 Stratego 棋一样，但要玩上 24 小时，不赢也不输，但最后知道你会赢。
She had to win. Because every time she focused in on a new object, the fear that something horrible might happen was reignited.
她必须赢。因为每当她聚焦于一个新的物体时，会有可怕事情发生的恐惧就会重新点燃。
Can you tell us about the time you swallowed a knife?
你能告诉我们你吞下刀子的那次吗？
Which one?
哪一次？
Uh, I don't know.
呃，我不知道。
Just pick one?
随便挑一个？
How many times have you swallowed knives?
你吞过多少次刀子？
Four.
四次。
Cathy never got her hands on a real metal knife, just the plastic ones they used in the hospital. But the results weren't so different. A quick warning, what Cathy describes in the next minute or so is graphic. You might want to turn down the volume if you're sensitive.
Cathy 从未拿到过真正的金属刀，只是医院用的那种塑料刀。但结果没什么不同。快速警告，Cathy 接下来一分钟左右描述的内容比较生动。如果你很敏感，可能想调低音量。
I took a knife out of the kitchen. And I put it in my bra. And I asked if I could go to the bathroom. They let me go to the bathroom by myself. I went in, and I went to the bathroom. I swallowed the knife.
我从厨房拿了一把刀。我把它放进胸罩里。我问能不能去洗手间。他们让我独自去洗手间。我进去了，我去了洗手间。我吞下了那把刀。
I started bleeding out of my mouth. Well, my throat was bleeding. And I couldn't breathe right. I was going [GASPING]. I couldn't get a deep breath in.
我的嘴开始流血。我的喉咙在流血。我无法正常呼吸。我当时在[喘息]。我没法深呼吸。
Did it hurt right away when it was cutting your esophagus?
割伤食道的时候很疼吗？
Yeah. I had a hard time getting it down, because it was cutting me as I was putting it down.
是的。我很难把它吞下去，因为它在我放进去的时候就在割我。
And you didn't think, oh, my gosh, I might die?
你当时没想过，噢天哪，我可能会死吗？
No, it's not my thought at all. I kept thinking I had to get it down.
没有，根本没想过。我一直在想我必须把它吞下去。
And you didn't think, OK, I just can't? I need to pull it out.
你没想过，OK，我真的做不到？我需要把它拉出来。
No. I never thought that. Nope.
不。我从没那样想过。没有。
I got a fever of 106. And they saw the hole in my throat. And then they immediately did surgery. And I was in ICU for three weeks. And I couldn't eat because the hole was in my-- it needed repair. And I almost died then.
我发了 106 度的烧。他们看到了我喉咙里的洞。然后他们立即进行了手术。我在重症监护室呆了三周。我没法吃东西，因为那个洞在我的——需要修复。那时我差点就死了。
This wasn't even the closest Cathy came to dying. Once-- I'm sorry this is a little graphic-- she sneezed while swallowing a radio antenna. And it became lodged dangerously close to her brain stem. Doctors had to put her in a medically induced coma while they figured out how to extract it.
这甚至不是 Cathy 最接近死亡的一次。有一次——抱歉，这有点生动——她在吞下一根无线电天线时打了个喷嚏。它卡在了极其靠近大脑干的地方。医生不得不让她进入药物诱导的昏迷状态，同时想办法把它取出来。
Over the years, Cathy had more than 500 endoscopies, where surgeons inserted a tube down her throat and pulled the item out through it. She had more than a dozen invasive surgeries to remove objects and repair tears and holes in her stomach, intestines, and esophagus. One of Cathy's doctors told us she almost single-handedly trained an entire generation of surgical residents at his hospital's ER. Things got so bad that after Cathy turned 18, hospital staff went in front of a judge to get permission to put her in a straitjacket.
多年来，Cathy 做过 500 多次内窥镜检查，外科医生通过管道插进喉咙，把东西拉出来。她做过十几次侵入性手术，取出物体并修复胃、肠和食道的裂口和洞。Cathy 的一位医生告诉我们，她几乎凭一己之力培训了他所在医院急诊室的一整代住院医生。情况变得如此糟糕，以至于 Cathy 18 岁后，医院工作人员不得不去法官面前申请许可给她穿上约束衣。
No hospital wanted to keep me longer than they had to. So they shipped me around every six months, because I was a liability.
没有医院愿意留我超过必要的时间。所以他们每六个月就把我转来转去，因为我是一个累赘。
Did you have any thoughts at that time about what your future was looking like?
你当时对自己的未来有什么看法吗？
I didn't have a future. I didn't see a future. I wanted to die. I didn't have a way to die. I was in a straitjacket. I laid in a bed.
我没有未来。我看不到未来。我想死。但我没有自杀的方法。我穿着约束衣。我躺在床上。
What did you think about when you were in a straitjacket, laying in bed day after day?
当你穿着约束衣，日复一日地躺在床上时，你在想什么？
If I didn't have something on my mind to swallow, I don't remember thinking anything. I would just exist.
如果我脑子里没有要吞的东西，我不记得自己在想什么。我只是存在着。
When Cathy was 21, she was transferred to yet another new facility-- Taunton State Hospital. She was so heavily drugged when she arrived, she didn't wake up for about a week. And when she did, her muscles were so atrophied from being restrained she couldn't hold up her head or lift her arms.
Cathy 21 岁时，被转到了另一个新设施——陶顿州立医院。她到达时被药物控制得很厉害，昏睡了大约一周。当她醒来时，她的肌肉因为长期被束缚而萎缩得非常厉害，她甚至无法抬起头或举起双臂。
But Cathy says this hospital, Taunton, was different. The doctors and staff were willing to give her a chance. They set up a system of rewards she could work toward. Each day she went without swallowing something, she was allowed one hour out of the straitjacket.
但 Cathy 说这家陶顿医院不一样。医生和工作人员愿意给她一个机会。他们建立了一套她可以争取奖励的系统。每天只要她没吞东西，就被允许脱掉约束衣一个小时。
They helped her build muscle tone back in her arms by walking her hands up and down the walls. They showed her a bit of kindness. After a winter storm, they brought her a snowball, something she hadn't felt in about 10 years.
他们通过引导她的手在墙上上下移动，帮助她恢复手臂的肌肉张力。他们对她展现了一点点善意。一场冬雪之后，他们带给她一个雪球，那是她大约 10 年来第一次感受到的东西。
And it was at Taunton that Cathy had a chance encounter that changed her life. Her regular psychiatrist went on vacation, and another doctor filled in for him. He was familiar with a relatively unknown surgery for extreme cases of OCD that he thought might help Cathy. It was a controversial procedure, mostly because when people hear about brain surgery on mentally ill patients, they immediately think of a lobotomy.
就是在陶顿，Cathy 经历了一次改变她生命的偶遇。她的常规精神科医生去度假了，另一位医生接替了他的工作。他了解一种相对不为人知的手术，用于治疗极端强迫症病例，他认为这可能对 Cathy 有帮助。这是一个有争议的手术，主要是因为当人们听说对精神病患者进行脑部手术时，会立刻想到脑叶切除术。
This wasn't a lobotomy. It was much more high-tech and precise than that. But it would mean destroying a small section of Cathy's brain. The idea was that surgeons could burn out a piece of the circuit they believed was malfunctioning-- the circuit that communicated between the emotional and logical parts of Cathy's brain.
这不是脑叶切除术。它比那更具高科技和精确性。但这意味着要破坏 Cathy 大脑的一小部分。这个想法是，外科医生可以烧掉他们认为功能失调的电路中的一小部分——连接 Cathy 大脑情感部分和逻辑部分的电路。
Only one hospital in the country offered the procedure regularly. And it happened to be near Cathy-- Massachusetts General. They had been doing it for decades. And they had found that the risks were low. More than half of the OCD patients who got the surgery improved. And for those that didn't, the side effects were minor.
全国只有一家医院定期提供这项手术。碰巧就在 Cathy 附近——马萨诸塞州总医院。他们已经做了几十年了。他们发现风险很低。超过一半接受手术的强迫症患者病情得到了改善。而对于那些没有改善的患者，副作用也很小。
So Cathy agreed to try it. It took about two hours. And amazingly, after she got out of the surgery, she immediately felt different. Her urge to swallow had vanished completely.
所以 Cathy 同意尝试一下。手术大约持续了两个小时。令人惊讶的是，手术后，她立刻感觉到了不同。她吞咽的冲动完全消失了。
In the beginning I was weary. I'm like, is it really gone? And then I swallowed something, like, two months after I had the procedure. It wasn't that I had the urge. I was so used to swallowing that it was so odd that I didn't feel the urge to swallow. And I'm like, well, maybe I should just swallow something.
刚开始我还有点担心。我在想，它真的消失了吗？然后，手术两个月后，我吞了一些东西。不是因为我有冲动。我是太习惯于吞咽了，以至于我不感到吞咽冲动反而觉得很奇怪。我在想，嗯，也许我该吞点什么。
I'm like, something's missing in my life, you know? It was like an old friend. But after I did it, I'm like, this isn't me. I don't want this.
我在想，我的生活中缺了点什么，你知道吗？它就像一个老朋友。但做完之后，我想，这根本不是我。我不想要这个。
That feeling lasted almost a year, until Cathy relapsed. The obsession came back. And she started swallowing again. So doctors did a second surgery and destroyed a little more of her brain. Again, Cathy woke up and the thought was gone. Again, she moved forward warily, not sure if it would last.
那种感觉持续了近一年，直到 Cathy 复发了。强迫症又回来了。她又开始吞东西。所以医生做了第二次手术，又破坏了她大脑的一小部分。Cathy 再次醒来，那个念头又消失了。她再次谨慎地向前走，不确定它能持续多久。
As the months passed, she began earning more freedom in the psych hospital. She was out of the straitjacket for good. Staff let her walk around the grounds of the hospital freely.
随着几个月过去，她开始在精神病院获得更多的自由。她永久性地脱掉了约束衣。工作人员让她在医院的庭院里自由走动。
But recovery wasn't easy. Even moments that should have been exciting were challenging instead. Like when she went home for the first time. After spending 10 years confined, mostly in restraints, to mental institutions, she was allowed to go to her mom's house for dinner.
但康复并不容易。即使是本应令人兴奋的时刻也充满了挑战。就像她第一次回家时。在被限制了 10 年，大部分时间被束缚在精神病院后，她被允许去母亲家吃晚饭。
It was odd because there were knives. There were all these things that I saw that I'm not used to seeing. Because we had filet mignon and rice pilaf. And it was an odd feeling to cut my steak with a steak knife.
感觉很奇怪，因为那里有刀子。有所有这些我看到但又不习惯的东西。因为我们吃的是菲力牛排和米饭。用牛排刀切牛排是一种很奇怪的感觉。
Did it make you nervous?
它让你紧张吗？
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know how to explain it. I'm like, a sharp knife. Then I'm like, oh my God.
是的。是的。我不知道怎么解释。我心想，一把锋利的刀。然后我想，噢，我的天哪。
[DOOR CLOSING]
[门关上的声音]
This is a little messy, if you don't mind mess.
这有点乱，如果你不介意的话。
More than a decade later, Cathy's showing us around her apartment. When she first moved out on her own, she was 28. Though she essentially had the life skills of a 13-year-old. She had to learn how to cook, how to clean. Her doctor sent someone to teach her how to shower by herself.
十多年过去了，Cathy 带着我们参观她的公寓。她第一次自己搬出来住时是 28 岁。尽管她基本只有 13 岁的生存技能。她必须学习如何做饭，如何打扫。她的医生派人教她如何独自洗澡。
For like the first month, I probably didn't sleep during the night at all because I had the freedom. I wasn't told to go to bed. So I was just basking in the glory of smoking cigarettes and drinking coffee all night. For like a month I did that. And I would sleep during the day, just because I could.
大概第一个月，我晚上可能根本没睡，因为我有自由。没人叫我去睡觉。所以我只是沉浸在整夜抽烟喝咖啡的荣耀中。大概一个月我都是那样。我白天睡觉，仅仅因为我可以。
Did the world feel foreign to you?
世界对你来说感到陌生吗？
It felt big, enormous.
它感觉很大，巨大无比。
Since then, Cathy's earned her GED and has taken a few classes at community college. These days, she checks in with her therapist every six months or so. She has a good life. She's funny, easy to talk to.
从那时起，Cathy 拿到了 GED 证书，并在社区学院上过几门课。这些天，她大约每六个月去见一次治疗师。她过着很好的生活。她风趣幽默，很好沟通。
You really don't want to see my bedroom.
你真的不想看我的卧室。
She shares this apartment with her boyfriend of eight years. There's an extra bedroom for her nieces and nephews to stay in when they visit. It's also where Cathy and her boyfriend keep the fishing rods they use on their boat each weekend. There are framed pictures of her family and friends, toys for the kids, and of course, toothbrushes, and forks, and knives.
她和相处了八年的男友合租这套公寓。有一个额外的卧室供侄子和侄女来访时居住。那里也是 Cathy 和男友存放他们每个周末在船上钓鱼时用的鱼竿的地方。墙上挂着她家人和朋友的照片，孩子们的玩具，当然还有牙刷、叉子和刀子。
Every single one of these things that are my house I cherish-- every single one of them. I collect pens now.
我家里的每一件东西我都非常珍惜——每一件。我现在收集笔。
Pens?
笔？
Pens. I have a whole jar of pens over there because they wouldn't allow me to have them for so many years. And now I can have them. And they don't torture me. So I collect them just to say where I've been and where I am now.
笔。我那边有一大罐笔，因为很多年来他们都不允许我拥有它们。现在我可以拥有它们了。它们不会折磨我。所以我收集它们，只是为了说明我经历过什么，以及我现在在哪儿。
We went over to the desk in the corner of her living room. Cathy picked up a mug filled with pens.
我们走到客厅角落的桌子旁。Cathy 拿起一个装满笔的马克杯。
They're just different kinds of pens.
它们只是不同种类的笔。
One came from TD Bank, one from the Institution for Savings. A friend gave her another. Now she can take one out of her collection and jot down a grocery list or a note to her boyfriend.
一支来自道明银行（TD Bank），一支来自存款机构。朋友给了她另一支。现在她可以从收藏中拿出一支，随手写写购物清单或给男友留个便条。
Jessica Benko in New York.
纽约的 Jessica Benko。
Act Four, "The Sweet Year After." In the aftermath of some terrible incident that nearly kills you, turns out things can be kind of great. Tim Kreider explains how.
第四幕，“劫后余生的甜美一年”。在经历了某件差点杀了你的可怕事件之后，事实证明事情可能会变得非常好。Tim Kreider 解释了原因。
17 years ago, I was stabbed in the throat. This is kind of a long story, and less interesting than it sounds. Except for the 10 or 15 minutes during which it looked like I was about to die, which I would prefer not to relive, getting stabbed wasn't even among the worst experiences of my life. In fact, it was one of the best things that ever happened to me.
17 年前，我的喉咙被刺伤了。这是一个很长的故事，并不像听起来那么有趣。除了那 10 到 15 分钟里，我看起来好像快要死掉了（那段经历我不想重温），被刺伤甚至不是我一生中最糟糕的经历之一。事实上，那是我发生过的最好的事情之一。
After my unsuccessful murder, I wasn't unhappy for an entire year. Winston Churchill's description of the exhilaration of being shot at without result is verifiably true. I'm not claiming to have been continuously euphoric the whole time. It's just that during that grace period, nothing much could bother me or get me down.
在这次不成功的谋杀之后，我整整一年都没感到不快乐。温斯顿·丘吉尔关于被枪击而毫发无伤的兴奋感的描述，是完全真实的。我并不是说我整个过程都持续处于狂喜之中。只是在那段宽限期内，没有什么能真正困扰我或让我沮丧。
The horrible thing I'd always dreaded was going to happen to me had finally happened. I figured I was off the hook for a while. In a parallel universe only two millimeters away, the distance between my carotid and the stiletto, I would have been flown home in the cargo hold instead of in coach.
我一直担心会发生在我身上的那件可怕的事情终于发生了。我想我暂时可以松一口气了。在仅两毫米距离的平行宇宙里，也就是颈动脉和细高跟鞋鞋跟之间的距离，我本会被装在货舱里而不是经济舱里被运回家。
I started brewing my own dandelion wine in a big Amish crock. I listened to old one hit wonders, much too embarrassing to name in public. And I developed a strange new laugh that's stayed with me to this day-- a loud, raucous barking thing. It makes people in bars or restaurants look over for a second to make sure I'm not about to open up on the crowd with a weapon.
我开始在一个大的阿米什陶罐里酿造自己的蒲公英酒。我听着古老的单曲红人歌曲，在公共场合提起它们太令人尴尬了。我还发展出一种奇怪的新笑声，一直伴随我至今——一种大声、喧闹、咆哮式的笑声。它会让酒吧或餐馆里的人看过来一秒钟，以确保我不是要用什么武器向人群扫射。
Not for one passing moment did it occur to me that God must have spared my life for some purpose. Even if I had been the type who was prone to such notions, I would have been disabused of it by the heavy-handed coincidence of the Oklahoma City bombing occurring on the same day I spent in a recuperative coma. If there is some divine plan that requires my survival and the deaths of all those children in daycare, I respectfully decline to participate.
我从来没有一瞬间认为上帝一定是为了什么目的才饶我一命。即使我是那种倾向于这种观念的人，奥克拉荷马城爆炸案发生在我处于康复昏迷的那一天，这种沉重的巧合也足以打破我的迷信。如果有什么神圣的计划需要我幸存而让那些日托所里的孩子们死亡，那我恭敬地拒绝参与。
What I had been was not blessed or chosen, but lucky. Which is not to turn my nose up at luck. It's better to be lucky than just about anything else in life. And if you're hearing this now, you're among the lucky, too.
我所得到的并非是被祝福或被选中，而是幸运。这并不是要拒绝幸运。能在生活中保持幸运比任何事情都好。如果你现在听到这个，那你也是幸运儿。
You'd like to think that nearly getting killed would be a permanently life-altering experience. But getting stabbed was like a lightning strike-- over almost as soon as it happened, and the illumination didn't last. You can't feel crazily grateful to be alive your whole life anymore than you can stay passionately in love forever, or grieve forever for that matter. Time makes us all betray ourselves and get back to the busy work of living.
你愿意认为差点送命会是一种永久改变生活的经历。但被刺伤就像一道闪电——几乎在发生后就结束了，那种光亮并没有持续下去。你不可能像永远保持激情恋情一样，终生感到极其幸运，正如你不可能永远哀悼一样。时间使我们背叛自己，重新回到忙碌的生存工作中。
It's easy now to dismiss that year as nothing more than the same sort of shaky, hysterical high you'd feel after being clipped by a taxi. But you could also try to think of it as a rare glimpse of reality, being jolted out of a lifelong stupor. I can't recapture that feeling of euphoric gratitude any more than I can really remember the mortal terror I felt when I was pretty sure I had about four minutes to live. But I know that it really happened, that that state of grace is accessible to us, even if I only blundered across it once and never find my way back.
现在很容易把那一年不经意地归结为那种在被出租车刮倒后感受到的同样摇摇欲坠的歇斯底里的快感。但你也可以试着把它看作是对现实的一种罕见瞥见，从终生的麻木中被猛然惊醒。我无法找回那种狂喜的感激感，就像我无法真正记住我确信自己还有四分钟可活时的那种致命恐惧一样。但我知道那真的发生过，那种恩典状态对我们每个人来说都是可触及的，即使我只是偶然闯入过一次，却再也找不到回去的路。
At my cabin on the Chesapeake Bay, I'll sometimes see bald eagles swoop up from the water with wriggling little fish in their talons. And whenever they accidentally drop their catch, I like to imagine that fish trying to tell his friends about his own near-death experience, a perspective so unprecedented there are no words in the fish language to describe it. For a short time, he was outside the world. He could see forever. There's so much more than they knew. But he's glad to be back.
在切萨皮克湾的小木屋里，我有时会看到秃鹰从水中俯冲而下，爪子里抓着扭动的小鱼。每当它们不小心掉下捕获物，我就喜欢想象那条鱼试图告诉朋友们它自己的濒死经历，那是一种前所未有的视角，以至于鱼的语言中没有词语可以描述它。在短暂的时间里，它在世界之外。它可以看到永远。那里比它们知道的要多得多。但它很高兴能回来。
Tim Kreidor reading an excerpt from his book of essays and cartoons with the really wonderful name We Learn Nothing.
Tim Kreidor 读了他散文和漫画集中的片段，书名非常棒，叫《我们什么都没学会》。
[MUSIC-- "SURVIVAL SONG," BY ANDREW JACKSON JIHAD]
[音乐——“生存之歌”，Andrew Jackson Jihad]
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们今天的节目由 Brian Reed 制作，参与人员包括 Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sarah Koenig、Jonathan Menjivar、Lisa Pollak、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp 和 Nancy Updike。
Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Tarek Fouda. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our office manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant.
我们的资深制作人是 Julie Snyder。制作帮助来自 Tarek Fouda。Seth Lind 是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon 是我们的办公室经理。Elise Bergerson 是我们的行政助理。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our new film, Sleepwalk With Me is still in tons of theaters. Like any comedy, it's always more fun to see in a movie theater with a crowd of people.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们的新电影《梦游症》仍在大量电影院上映。像任何喜剧一样，在电影院里和人群一起观看总是更有趣。
But if you are one of the many, many people who actually comprise the majority of people in our country, maybe you've got kids, maybe you stay at home, you don't get out to movies much, I'm excited to announce that our film is available now on VOD-- Video On Demand-- through most cable operators and satellite providers. You can watch it right now, tonight. Or we are encouraging everybody-- we have this idea to throw pizza parties this coming Friday night, October 12, Friday night. Invite over friends, order some pizzas, watch the film.
但如果你是我们国家人口中占绝大多数的许多人中的一员，也许你有孩子，也许你待在家里，不常去电影院，我很兴奋地宣布，我们的电影现在可以通过大多数有线电视运营商和卫星供应商点播（VOD）。你现在就可以观看，就在今晚。我们鼓励每个人——我们有个想法，这个周五晚上，10 月 12 日，周五晚上举办披萨派对。邀请朋友过来，点些披萨，一起看电影。
Mike Birbiglia, who stars in the film, and I will be Skyping and video chatting into as many parties as we can. To sign up for that and to let us know how to reach you on Friday, go to our website-- thisamericanlife.org.
电影主演 Mike Birbiglia 和我将通过 Skype 和视频聊天加入尽可能多的聚会。要报名参加并让我们知道周五如何联系你，请访问我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. His reaction to the presidential debate this week-- he turns it on, and I guess, I don't know, he was really put off by the president's performance.
WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监管来自我们的老板，Torey Malatia 先生。他对本周总统辩论的反应——他打开电视，我猜，我不知道，他真的被总统的表现搞得很不舒服。
I'm on fire. I'm burning up.
我在燃烧。我在发高烧。
Well, understandable, I guess. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
好吧，我想这是可以理解的。我是 Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC-- "SURVIVAL SONG," BY ANDREW JACKSON JIHAD]
[音乐——“生存之歌”，Andrew Jackson Jihad]
PRI-- Public Radio International.
PRI——公共广播国际公司。